[Music]
the following program contains the
opinions of its hosts and guests not
those of this network the opinions
expressed are for non-commercial
informational purposes only listeners
are cautioned not to rely on program
content to treat or prevent disease but
are advised to consult with a licensed
health-care professional where they live
for diagnosis and treatment of disease
and now the superstar of alternative
health and purveyor of medical truth dr.
joel wallach hello and welcome to dead
doctors don't lie dr. golmaal like your
host a veterinarian and position and i'm
here for kids and baby boomers and
seniors who don't want to die at 75.5
like their parents and grandparents I'm
here for kids and baby boomers and
seniors we don't want to be sick and
miserable to last 15 to 20 years of
their life like their parents and
grandparents I am a conservative a lot
of people say I treat them like dogs but
they do they need to get better now they
have a personal health challenge when
asked about you know health challenge of
a friend a loved one a workmate aren't
going to talk about medical politics or
the home based business opportunity it
was it call toll-free 1877 379 2552 well
I'm sorry that's triple 8 I got there
wrong here's one triple eight 379 2552
again is toll-free one triple eight 379
2552 now in today's USA Today today
headline front page colon cancer surgeon
Millennials and Generation X is a 40
year study it was just published in the
Journal of the National Cancer Institute
the journal the National Cancer
Institute just published they said
result shows as someone born in nineteen
ninety has double the risk of early
colon cancer and quadruple quadruple the
risk or early rectal cancer and someone
born in nineteen fifty
okay and so the tells you is there
something going on between 1950 and 1992
set all this up all right what's going
on here well 1952 1952 our dear friend
Ancel Keys brokered the deal between the
American Heart Association and Procter &
Gamble to have Procter & Gamble give the
American Heart Association 1.7 million
dollars to endorse Crisco oil and solid
shortening a safer healthier way to cook
in lard butter cream and eggs and they
came out then everybody came out with
margins replaced butter it and non-dairy
coffee creamers to replace cream for
your coffee and tea okay and also get
rid of butter okay go to margin and
let's see here oh yeah eight meters an
egg white omelets instead of eggs all of
which had cholesterol and saturated so
they went all these oils transplant
settle second means acrylamides also
during that time we've got microwave
popcorn which causes 50,000 heart
attacks and 20,000 deaths and kids under
the age of 10 just from the heterocyclic
amines and trans fats causing plaque in
the arteries okay not close from
saturated fat well it's been shown and I
said this in 71 and just last year the
World Health Organization came out and
said processed meats they were talking
about deli slices sandwich meat sausage
ham bacon Bologna salami pastrami
pepperoni jerky Carmy spam increases the
risk of all cancers okay and so we have
a problem here we've been driven down
the wrong road by the medical profession
on what he would not eat and what we get
for it obesity another disease of
deficiency has nothing eating too much
lack of exercise type 2 diabetes a
deficiency have a single nutrient has
nothing to do with obesity and then of
course let's see here we have cancer
which you just spoke about and then we
have arthritis all the nutrients
necessary to prevent reverse our drives
are no longer found in her food birth
defects every birth defects you can name
in 10 times as many you can't we've been
eliminating the animal history
preconception nutrition and supplement
there's no birth defect that is caused
by genetics hello Alzheimer disease is
caused by deficiency of a single
nutrient ok and let's see here fatty
liver oil this is a big one coming
because it seemed that causes fatty
liver is high intakes of carbohydrates
and of course sugar sugar is one of the
biggest guilty parties here when it
comes to a inflammatory disease and your
arteries cancer and everything else the
sugar industry paid doctors and
researchers thousands and thousands
maybe fifty thousand dollars each to not
reveal their findings and so sugar was
kind of left alone let's all eat high
carbohydrate diet give up fat what we
get oh got more obesity more diabeetus
more cancer okay and so including colon
or rectal cancer it's just obscene what
the medical system has done to the
American public in the world in general
okay by giving people false information
so the Procter & Gamble can sell Crisco
because very very scary when you think
about it and so the genetics things has
led people down the wrong path has
another failed theory did you texting
it's called epigenetics your jeans are
good oh but they do require all 90
essential nutrients 60 mineral 16
bottoms 12 mm sorry fatty acid so I urge
you to get a hold of your young give
associate and as for the book the CD and
DVD dead doctors no life find out all
the naughty stuff the doctors do to pad
their wallets and not take care of you
epigenetics the death of the genetic 3g
transmission the CD is public enemy
number one the DVD is somebody needs to
go to jail that's epigenetics the depth
of the genetic disease transmission
rare-earth been cured two CDs I want you
to get one is what kills billionaires
and the emblem is dead athletes don't
lives but athletes supposed to be the
healthiest people of all personal
athletes Olympic athletes they get paid
enormous amounts of money just to do
their hobby exercise live right eat
right do all the right things all Arish
professional athlete only lives to these
62 regardless of the sport except for
football players is 51 there's will have
been only one professional athlete let's
be a hundred in the last hundred years
all the rest of them died summer
a little bit around 62 or 51 if you're a
football player so what gives here well
we've been given a lot of misinformation
by the medical trade okay which results
in two hundred fifty one thousand deaths
from mistakes 15 million deaths and
injuries and infections by agreed upon
proper medical treatment as yearly if a
foreign country like Iran or North Korea
were to do that we declare war on them
here's one trade it does it every every
year in their own workplace and nobody
does they don't get an OSHA ticket so
again I urge you to get a hold of your
giving you so sheís get ahold of the
books dead doctor to live the
epigenetics and rivers injures hit on
the 90th cents on your skin you're the
bad stuff out of your guys and I'm out
supplemental data bad diets let's go up
fried foods such as meat oils and blues
and take your ninety cents addictions
and read dead ducks July of each
experiment here and we'll be back with
dead doctors don't lie you're listening
to dead doctors don't Lyle the CBS radio
network with your host dr. joel wallach
if you'd like to talk to dr. wallet call
us toll-free 888 379 2552 on the
priority light 83 1685 1080
[Music]
in recent years several studies have
discovered the healthy benefits of
drinking coffee youngevity has now taken
it a step further with an entire product
line of healthy coffees from youngevity
java fit selection of top shelf gourmet
coffees all java fit coffees are made
from one hundred percent premium hand
selected iraq of a coffee beans grown in
the finest regions of latin america
carefully roasted creating a delicious
rich full-bodied flavor try java fits
original roast a perfect blend of mellow
and smooth with just the right
full-bodied depth to make an aromatic
and enjoyable cup of coffee traditional
as well as organic and fair trade
options also available in 30 count
single cup or 24 count single pot packs
contact your local FDI Youngevity
distributor to get java lucien coffees
and don't forget to ask about home based
business opportunities hey if you're
like me your life is hectic you don't
know where you're gonna be next between
kids and family and inlaws and work and
traffic and everything else ice driving
me crazy right now my wife is insane I
bet your life's insane as well when do
we have time to get every single
nutrient we need to be healthy when well
I've got tip for you take a product
called Paul and burst it's so simple
even I can do it all you have to do is
open the package pour it in water mix it
up and bam you're ready to go it tastes
great it's not one of those medicine
tasting things it tastes great low in
calories helps curb your appetite gives
you natural energy that doesn't let you
crash gives you your vitamins minerals
nutrients everything from the plant
world and i gotta tell you for a busy
person like me or a busy person like you
we need simple we need good poem versus
your answer tastes great try it and
you'll feel better call your local
youngevity distributor to find out how
pollen burst can make you feel better
ahead don't forget to ask about home
based business opportunities
[Music]
we're fat with dead doctors don't lie on
the CBS radio network dr. joel wallach
here for youngevity next lecture say we
do have lines open give us a call toll
free one triple eight 379 2552 and
toll-free one triple eight 379 2552 and
if you need to lose 10 25 50 75 100
pounds or more contact for young GV
associate and as for the books Hell's
Kitchen and energy crisis learn how to
get on the keto diet we actually have a
keto diet which is a keto shake and
Aikido bar you want a high protein high
fat diet get really carbohydrates on
your life that was bad information by
the medical system Oh eat more carbs
just stay away from fat wrong
information again get ahold of books
Hell's Kitchen and energy crisis and do
you buy the books from your young TV
associate as for free copies of seed
beaten CD by the same title Hell's
Kitchen okay Doug what pearls wisdom you
have for us well this would cut a
surprise me it's a story that i got from
fox news that is headlined obesity
strongly linked to 811 types of cancer
is say people who are obese have a
greater risk of developing and dying
from several types of cancer including
malignancies for a breast ovary kidney
pancreas colon rectum and bone marrow
cancers they say cancer is a leading
cause of death worldwide the prevalence
of obesity has more than doubled over
the past generation excess weight is
thought to influence the odds have died
from a wide variety of tumors a study
found quote strong evidence supporting
the connection to 11 cancers according
to the lead author dr. maria to rig you
of the imperial college london says
other associations could also be genuine
but there is still a substantial
uncertainty among them it's a globally
1.9 billion that's billion with a be
adults are overweight or obese according
to the world health organization say
roughly four in 10 adults are overweight
more than wanted 10 are obese including
that increases the risk for heart
disease diabetes kidney problems joint
disorders
to cancers for this study they analyzed
results of 204 previously published
studies exploring the connection between
obesity weight gade waist circumference
and 36 different cancers looked at
particular for evidence that the
previous results might have been
exaggerated the link between the obesity
of the cancer or found a connection that
it was too small to rule out the
possibility that was due to chance if
found the strongest leaks were between
obesity and malignancies of the
digestive organs and for hormone related
tumors in women this was all reported in
the British Medical Journal and
researchers found increases in the BMI
were tied to higher risk of developing
cancers in the esophagus bone marrow
biliary tract system pancreas and kidney
uptick said the BMI were also lead to
greater odds of colon rectal cancers in
men and as well as in Demetrio
malignancies of younger women the
increased risk for cancer for every five
year to gated BMI range from nine
percent for rectal cancer among men to
fifty six percent for tumors in the
biliary tract system and for women the
weight game and extra belly fat were
also associated with an increased risk
of certain cancers and as women added
more fat around the midsection for every
0.1 unit increase in waist to hip ratio
was associated with a 21-percent jump in
the odds of inter lead in de metrio
cancer wow that's pretty crazy yeah and
of course what causes people be
overweight and obese in nutritional
deficiencies okay so you're
nutritionally deficient when you're
obese and then you throw in a high carb
diet trying to you know follow the
medical thank you up at eat more
carbohydrates which is inflammatory
increases your risk of cancer we need a
high carb high sugar diet and you are
deficient nutrient so save a gluten
intolerance you can't absorb nutrients
and so it all kind of goes together so I
think we deserve a flourish on that one
she'd probably have here Doug is that
the medical system does not want to
admit that their advice for everybody to
give up fat and eat carbohydrates and
sugar instead of fat that they'd be
safer from artery disease everything
they said was wrong and they're not
going to step up to the plate ensayo
responsible for the deaths of 1 billion
people over the last 50 years in the
industrialized world because it gave
them wrong advice you know how many
lawyers are going to line up and 1 800
bad advice and there will be more
lawsuits and when they finally read the
book epigenetics the death of the jeddak
3 disease transmission the lawyers are
going to be lining up watch for it it's
going to happen be back with dead doctor
no live for these messages you're
listening to dead doctors don't lie all
the CBS radio network with your host dr.
joel wallach you'd like to talk to dr.
wallet call us between noon and one
pacific at 83 1685 1080 toll-free 888
379 2552
[Music]
aromatherapy oils have been prized by
ancient cultures for thousands of years
young japanese ancient legacy true
aromatherapy is no exception essential
oils are the fragrant life essence from
plants that are gently removed through
the process of steam distillation
youngevity ancient legacy essential oils
are of the purest concentrations from
the most respected and ethical
distillers worldwide middy of ancient
legacies oils come directly from
families in the east which have been
distilling essential oils for over 100
years for life's everyday aches and
pains such as sprained ankles pulled
muscles and other bumps and bruises try
ancient legacy trauma oil which contains
essential oils traditionally node to
help with pain swelling and inflammation
to learn more about aromatherapy and
essential oils contact your local
youngevity associate today and don't
forget to ask about business
opportunities hi everyone and the
Anderson here are you using those handy
little bottles of jail that zap germs
bacteria and other nasties in today's
world that's smart especially with all
the filthy doorknobs shopping carts and
handrails we touch every day here's what
you may not know once the alcohol
evaporates goodbye effectiveness no more
protection until you use it again pure
works to the rescue our FDA compliant
foam lotion soap and spray do not rely
on alcohol they're killing power lasts
up to four hours pure work disinfecting
spray is EPA certified to kill swine flu
bird flu mersa HIV hepatitis B and
seeing a whole host of viruses and
bacteria mold and fungus too it's even
safe around children and pets you'll
love the soft feel of pure works on your
hand it actually conditions that will
not dry your skin here's a little peace
of mind knowing your hands are still
germ-free hours later get your hands on
pure works and get pure works on your
hands stand by pull out your paper and
pencil for your local number to order
pure works you've listed to physician ad
veterinarian dr. joel wallach help many
people all the dead doctors don't lie
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how dr. wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
dr. Wallach is
to something and you want to try your
Japanese premium quality products for
yourself we could connect you with the
distributor that serves your local area
simply call our special helpline
voicemail at 31 34 44 3463 that's 31 34
44 3463 call right now and leave your
name telephone number or email address
and we'll see to it that the right
person contact you shortly remember the
phone number 31 34 44 3463 that's 31 34
44 3 4 6 3 call down to change your life
that's 31 34 44 3463
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't line
the CBS radio network dr. joel wallach
here for young Jimmy narcolepsy Sade we
do have lines open give us a call toll
free one triple eight 379 2552 again
that's toll-free one triple eight 379
2552 and if you're going to do the young
givi business as a business i urge you
to contact young give you associate and
ask for that trilogy of books let's play
doctor let the herbal doctor in the
passport chromatherapy and learn how to
deal with over 900 different diseases
using vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals and rare earths amino acids
fatty as its herbs aromatherapy oils
that's the trilogy of books let's play
doctor lets her herbal got from the
passport roma therapy and of course if
you have no experience in running your
own business asked also for the book
ball street for kids learn how to be
profitable learn how to impact at the
same tax breaks to billionaires yet we
don't want to take away their tax breaks
we want to get the tax breaks and you
have to own your own business to get the
tax breaks okay douglas go to colors
alright let's head to Texas and Georgia
rod with dr. Wallach well Jordan you're
on the air well thank you dr. Hawke is
good to finally get to talk to you I
actually have a question about a cat a
cat of mine and he seems to drool a lot
and it typically contains like he
drooled a lot of mucus and he has bad
breath he has like a little sore too on
his tongue and half the time he has a
tongue kind of hanging out so I don't
know if you know what's going on with
that or what well his veterinarian
looked at him unfortunately I have not
been able to do that okay well you could
have anything from a abscessed tooth to
have a cracked tooth could have
something going on with his tonsils you
could have a foreign body in his mouth
I've seen that some were you know cats
outside these chasing a bug and gets a
piece of stick rammed into his throat
and you have a foreign body and they're
like a stick or something so if you can
kind of feel around in there in the back
of a certain so you can find the stick
or a wire or a pin kind of thing
sometimes they'll grab on to something
and it will have a pin in it and and
they have this pin stuck in their throat
and so it could be a foreign body in
there the secondary infection which
gives us the odor so that's kind of what
I would look for
something of that nature and either
abscess tooth a cracked tooth to foreign
body stuck in the throat how does a cat
um he is what c3 he's four years old I
don't think he has an abscess tooth
because he eats food and shoes without
any pain like normal he's an inside cat
so he hasn't been going outside and
getting any kind of like sticks or if I
doubt any foreign things like that so I
don't think it's either of those you
choose without pain you know well I go
ahead and have somebody you know look in
there they have a veterinarian look in
there and see there's anything going on
but again you know there's pins in the
household in the rug in in the couch and
so forth and they pick up some shiny ins
and swallow it gets stuck in their
throat that's all possibilities but
other than that he's eating and so on
char your ear a small critter person
what would you do for a four a five
pound cat to give them some kind of
antiseptic effect down his throat would
you give them I give them some colloidal
silver you get an eight plus I'd go
ahead and give him a dropper full just
spray that in the back of his stroke and
see you know if it's something as simple
as kind like a strep throat kind of
thing but was since he's drooling and
how long has been going on it's been I
would say roughly the last half heater
but it's increased over the last six
months give or take maybe late those
World unfortunately we've kept them yet
yeah I would vote on a foreign body so
I'd take him to vet Mary and hem
examines give a thumbs back there and
sometimes you have to see it on an x-ray
or something to their head and neck but
guess i just put the colloidal silver in
his mouth just straight and fact you can
even put in a spray bottle a couple
ounces of water and spray him in the
throat three times a day and we'll be
back i think after these messages that
correct that is correct we're headed to
a local break here and you are listening
to dead doctors don't lie are the CBS
radio network with your host dr. joel
wallach if you'd like to talk to dr.
Wallach call us toll-free 888 379 255 to
that's triple eight
379 255 two lines open
[Music]
you've listed a physician and
veterinarian dr. joel wallach helped
many people on the dead doctors don't
lie talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how dr. wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
dr. Wallach is on to something and you
want to try your jeopardise premium
quality products for yourself we could
connect you with a distributor that
serves your local area simply call our
special helpline voicemail at 31 34 44
3463 that's 31 34 44 3463 call right now
and leave your name telephone number or
email address and we'll see to it that
the right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number 31 34 44 3463
that's 31 34 44 3463 call down to change
your life that's 31 34 44 3463 hi this
dr. joel wallach your host of dead
doctors don't lie if you're interested
in a colon cleanse blood clams liver
cleanse on the classical herbal way you
want to ask your youngevity associate
for herbal rainforest herbal rainforest
has 60 nerves 16 cleansing herbs classic
cleansing herbs and 77 plant minerals
that's right and these are all organic
it doesn't get any better than that in
your busy day you're around all these
toxins out there in your workplace on
the way home going to work in your food
in the air in the water you need herbal
rain pours I guarantee it it will give
you a cleanse you can control the dose
it's a liquid it tastes good it doesn't
get any better than this a colon that's
happy makes you happy nothing better
than a happy kollam herbal rainforest
clean it out for more information on
this product or others you've heard
about on the dead doctors don't lie
radio program call your local youngevity
associate today and don't forget to ask
about home based business opportunities
greetings everyone Judy devilbiss here
what do you think of when you hear the
words tangy tangerine well I think of
like a sweet tangy tasting something
well what I'm referring to is the
ultimate tangy 10
doreen it's a fantastic product it has
everything you need and a great benefit
is it's very very delicious is very easy
to drink I've suggested it even to
youngsters even children like even
little guys even little girls they come
right into my office their parents can't
get them to take those chewables and
besides that they're not as good as
tangy tangerine and I give them a little
taste of that and you know something
they're pleased as punch so if it's good
for a child and it tastes delicious why
not you there's no excuse not to take a
vitamin when it tastes as good as that
does so how about it tangy tangerine
should be the answer to all of your
nutritional program problem for more
information or to order call your
youngevity distributor today and don't
forget to ask about youngevity home
based business opportunities this is the
CBS radio network network
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
on the CBS radio network dr. joel
wallach europe young to be nice Lyfe you
say we do have lines open gipsa call
toll-free one triple eight 379 2552
again is toll-free one triple eight 379
2552 and if you want to live
considerably longer than a hundred years
of age say chronologically 110 120
hundred three hundred 1,400 1,500 1,600
1,700 1,800 1,900 plus well-being
biological you 30 40 50 contacts me I'll
give you associate and as for the book
epigenetics the death of the genic
theories each has the transmission the
book immortality and the book rare has
been cures and learn how you can add 25
to 50 healthy earth your life and even
equally important or maybe more
important they had 25 to 50 health years
to your kids your grandkids life and
find out why the top 20 longevity
cultures have 40 times 100 we do they
have 100 452 population you only have
one for 10,000 as the book epigenetics
the book immortality and the book rare
earth ventures okay Douglas good colors
alright let's head to California a
Danielle you're odd with dr. Wallach
hello Danielle you're on the air yeah hi
I called it a couple weeks ago because
i'm currently pregnant i also have
postural orthostatic tachycardia
syndrome and a history of
pregnancy-related blood clots the last
time I talked to you rescue you
recommended a couple of your products so
I was wondering if you can go over more
on the dosage for the beyond tangy
tangerine two point oh ok i wish you how
much you weigh 125 ok your help far
along in pregnancy 17 weeks okay like
four months yeah okay so basically in
125 pounds I would take one healthy
brain and hard pack per month and divide
everything in half second half of those
are in your breakfast in their time and
that will allow you to have three of the
FAA breakfast and through the fa pluses
dinner time and let's see here
I would also go ahead and get one of our
files dishes castles and take to those
twice today it'll be one bottle month as
per be complex okay and um let's see
here char what you do for the
tachycardia fast heartbeat what does
your doctor say good cause the past
heartbeat well they they they think it's
something wrong with your heart but
there's nothing wrong of your heart it's
a mechanical problem yeah usually and
did you have thank you card e before you
got pregnant or only after your pleasure
this one okay so you had before you have
a back problem no just all my pain and
neck okay have something going on your
neck okay and how call are you I 52 okay
so yeah maybe 10 pounds overweight a
little bit course you're four months
pregnant that could be the pregnancy but
yeah the package you have some neck pain
you could have some back problems
without pain but when you have issues
either bone spurs in your vertebrae or
you can have you Jenner just disease and
your disc or a little thinner than
normal the vertebrae get closer together
and they actually smash the roots of the
spinal nerves control the rate and
rhythm of your heart and of course
becoming pregnant will the Everett will
begin to suck nutrients out of your
bones and liver and every place else to
develop properly and so it's not unusual
for people to get a lot of problems you
know high blood pressure all kinds of
other stuff with pregnancy because the
embryo is stealing nutrients from you
and so there's tachycardia could be
degenerative disc disease or bone spurs
resulting in pinching the roots of this
founders between T 1 2 3 and 4 the first
horse rest vertebrae c 1 c 3 and 4 and
hang on i think that's it one tell deep
and hard times a month a half a dozen
ring twice a day and the D says castles
320 and the glucose L go ahead and take
three or four those twice a day in one
bottle month
and that should a good save supplemental
program or four month old embryo back at
these messages you're listening to dead
doctors don't lie on the CBS radio
network with your host dr. joel wallach
[Applause]
[Music]
you've listed a physician and
veterinarian dr. joel wallach helped
many people on the dead doctors don't
lie talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how dr. wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
dr. Wallach is on to something and you
want to try your Japanese premium
quality products for yourself we can
connect you with the distributor that
serves your local area simply call our
special helpline voicemail at 31 34 44
3463 that's 31 34 44 3463 call right now
and leave your name telephone number or
email address and we'll see to it that
the right person contact you shortly
remember the phone number 31 34 44 3463
that's 31 34 44 3463 call down to change
your life that's 31 34 44 3463 I am Judy
devilbiss Here I am speaking to you
again I just wanted to tell you that
recently I started drinking the way
shakes again the chocolate whey shake
and you need to remember the way shake
isn't just for losing weight it's a
fantastic place to get your great
protein and if you're trying to gain
weight you can take it along with your
meals and the best part is if you want
to just have a great protein shake do
like I do put it over ice stir it up and
you can sip on it for 20 minutes to an
hour I do it every single day I
absolutely love it you need to get back
to it too it's really good for you and
it makes not fat but it makes muscle
after you workout and you can also mix
it up in a blender with an egg and you
have the most incredible health protein
shake or mix it with a little water
stirred up and you have a little pudding
and who doesn't like puddin for more
information or to order call your
youngevity distributor today and don't
forget to ask about youngevity home
based business opportunities
[Music]
[Applause]
we're back with dead doctors don't line
a CBS Radio Network dr. joel wallach
here be on duty 95 to say we do have
lines open give us a call toll free one
triple eight 379 2552 it has toll-free
one triple eight 379 2552 and if you
have someone in your family who
exercised or they go to the gym they run
around the track they have machines at
home rowing machines treadmills these
kind of things to actually be safe and
reduce the risk of sudden heart death
card them up in your heart disease and
reduce the risk of ruptured aneurysms
these types of things which result from
certain deficiencies that can be
exaggerated or accelerated by sweating
because you sweat out these nutrients
I'm going to get hold of the book raros
ventures get ahold of the CD called dead
athletes don't lie and learn how you can
supplement properly to reduce those risk
of sudden heart death and ruptured
aneurysms and injuries your joints and
so forth and again let's see the book
wearers ventures and in the CD dead
athletes don't lie and don't forget to
ninety cents of nutrients and don't
forget rebound the drink it's a sports
drink it has a hundred nutrients in it
whereas Gatorade has to empower you have
six hour rebound has a hundred which one
do you want to take which one do you
want your grandkids to take which one
you want your kids to take okay Douglas
go to colors all right let's head to
Minnesota ed Robin your rod with dr.
Wallach Robin you're on the air hello I
heard me help you thank you so much for
being there really appreciate this yeah
I'm sitting here with my husband and um
he said to um we've been trying to do
things healthy for a long time but
somehow life turned around for us and he
got melanoma cancer on his skin mining
his face and I don't know how this
happened but we had to treat it somehow
because everything I put on it wouldn't
go away so he had to go to VA because
that's all we could afford and they
grabbed did all kind of things and now
the melanoma is
actually in his eye and so I know yeah
we don't want to go with radiation and
the whole bit and um it's very testing
and well how much do you weigh Robin
Hill is your husband way he's um 160
okay how tall is he he's i guess like
six now and you shrunk a little bit oh
absolutely yeah what should the trunk
you think um well you should be 62 he
said you two okay so he's drunk maybe
two inches okay all right yeah many
other issues too high pressure diabetes
arthritis big time dementia and look I
think any time I give him anything or
myself also we break out in red spots on
her skin so supplementation is really
strange I don't know why no we were told
we had heavy metals and candy dia and so
okay yeah so every time we were growing
up wait a minute women so when you said
big time when I asked you about diabetes
and arthritis and I would present so
which one is does he have all of them
are he doesn't have diabetes and it
doesn't have authorized now all his test
labs work came out great just having
infection even the liver of stuff was
great you know what they do in the
hospital VA sure but don't get work yeah
okay good so he shrunk a little bit all
right okay char what you do to support
Robin's husband's immune system because
we're looking for his immune system to
be the best friend here and do what it
can to fend off this melanoma has
metastasized it's a skin cancer sighs
was I and so won't you give a 160-pound
guy that needs some immune system
support here I would give him two
healthy brain and heart pacsun and I
would also add the ultimate daily
classic know that excuse me the BGT two
point O tablets for the org points and
then he he could also take immortelle
IAM for stem cell growth and i would
personally take the active and the
the few coins Eve okay let's see here
well what i would do is some of them i'd
give ninety percent which are set 160
pounds i have him go with the two
healthy brain and heart attacks a month
to pull those running twice a day or you
can divide it up into four half doses
during the day so he doesn't have to
take so much at once also because he's
80 years old when spread it out during
the day i also got give all the bad
foods the fried foods processed meats
oils and gluten so take the pressure off
the immune system i agree with the
beyond tangerine to point hotels he
could take two of those twice a day be
one bottle a month get the org points
over 160,000 or egg points a day and i
would leave out the other stuff except
for i would throw in may be easy radical
z radical to z like zebra dashing the
word radical i'd go ahead and haven't
take two ounces a day when a breakfast
one at dinnertime all that's going to
support his immune system i would leave
off the immortelle IAM and i would leave
off the octave for this particular
cancer in the eye thing i'd leave those
two off but everything else who had
taken them throwing the z radical z
radical again announced hi stage about a
month give her the bad stuff the fried
foods of constants means yalls blues and
then call us you know every time he goes
in for an exam going to keep us up to
date and we can kind of tweak things as
we go along here okay got to take care
of our veterans since he's going to the
VA hospital guess what he's got to be a
better all right Doug let's go to call
her so let's head to Pennsylvania and
Tom you're odd with dr. Wallach Tom
you're on the air oh hi hello dr.
Wallach thank you very much for taking
my call yeah I had two quick questions
for you here 11 is about my little dog
the other ones about my knee but that my
little dogs more important in my knee I
think anyway ok I love the guy a lot
he's a wonderful star would agree with
sharp would agree with you yeah well
anyway yeah my veterinarian diagnosed a
major return of is rett on a retina
problem called correo retinitis and he
has an iop of left third 15 and right 17
so he put them on because i'm afraid
he's going to go blind and we put them
on prednisone five milligrams once a day
and then also he's giving them decks of
Memphis or sisters dog way he weighs
about 11 pounds 12 pounds some point of
a mounds any others either just now the
only ama no comment okay so he didn't
fall out of the car run into anything or
okay so he just this is sort of a
degenerative problem in 11 years it's a
return a recurrence of a problem it
happened about a year ago and I didn't
notice he's having trouble focusing and
so on and the prednisone everything
seeing work with them but now all of a
sudden a 30 year later it's back
reoccurring and I wanted to give him the
other issues does he have any other
issues like skin comes in the itchy skin
or eczema doesn't know I don't seem to I
do give them their a max for his joints
uh but otherwise that's the only thing
he takes that's it and okay so let's get
on with this one so we can get to your
knee here as we got other people waiting
in line and so a sharp why would you do
you're a dog small dog lady 11 pounds
about the size of cocoa okay what did
you do for I problems in this dog and
also joint problems well I would give
him a half a scoop of the are three
jacks every day and depending on how you
know he can give him a quarter scoop
twice a day and then I would open up a
selenium and mix that in his food every
day yeah put you know half of capsule is
lame and breakfast and hammers it was
lame in the evening and the art projects
is a crystalyn multiple for dogs and
cats and as he igloo coje el how much
cooler jogeum um probably I give him at
least two a day okay to a day the glue
gel gives the capsules open them up but
one capsule breakfast when capsules
their time and then what would you do
for the eye itself well you could grind
up that octave and edit toys food I put
the ah cute to them absolutely want one
knock you to the capsule or tablet I
think it's a tablet hmm okay yeah i
would go ahead
and grind up one of those give them half
that round of octave and breakfast one
their time and and don't give any table
scraps particularly fried foods and oils
and things like that and then hang on
we'll be back with it we'll talk about
your knees Tom after these you're
listening to dead doctors don't lie or
the CBS radio network with your host dr.
joel wallach
[Music]
many believe that all life began in the
Earth's oceans we do know that the
oceans and seas are still abundant with
life and life sustaining nutrients many
cultures have long believed in the
life-giving properties of plants and sea
life harvested from the oceans young
japanese oceans gold is a proprietary
blend of seaweeds algie's losses kelp
sea cucumbers and sea minerals as well
as coenzyme q10 calcium and iron all
designed to help support healthy thyroid
function regular heartbeat normal weight
mood stabilization and hormone levels
take advantage of life-sustaining
nutrients from the Earth's oceans with
youngevity oceans gold if you'd like to
learn more about nutritional
supplementation call your local
youngevity associate and don't forget to
ask about home based business
opportunities hello Judy devilbiss here
if I could only afford to get one
product out of everything that product
would be the ultimate classic it has the
vitamins the minerals the bioflavonoids
it even has grape seed extract the one
product that would give you just about
everything under the Sun you would need
for a perfect nutritional program would
be the ultimate classic by the way
people that are on the go it's very very
hard to take the liquids with them when
they go on their trip to get their
supplements in every day well you know
something you can use the ultimate daily
tablets and the mineral capsules when
I'm going on a trip if I have enough
room I just take the two bottles with me
if not just use a little baggie and take
a couple of daily doses with you it's
very simple it's very easy there's no
mess no fuss no refrigeration just take
your capsules take your tablets and
you're finish for the day to order these
products call your local youngevity
distributor today you've listed a
physician and veterinarian dr. joel
wallach help many people on the dead
doctors don't lie talk radio program
you've also heard hundreds of people
tell how dr. wallach and youngevity
products have changed their lives if
you're now convinced that dr. Wallach is
on to something and you want to try your
jeopardy
premium quality products for yourself we
could connect you with the distributor
that serves your local area simply call
our special helpline voicemail at 31 34
44 3463 that's 31 34 44 3463 call right
now and leave your name telephone number
or email address and we'll see to it
that the right person contacts you
shortly remember the phone number 31 34
44 3463 that's 31 34 44 3463 call down
to change your life that's 31 34 44 3463
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't line
the CBS radio network dr. joel wallach
here feeling duty night black crusade
and Douglas go right back to
Pennsylvania um okay let's talk about
your knee Tom oh thank you very much
doctor yeah I used to wrestle quite a
bit years ago in high school and I
started having a knee problem where it
would really be just kind of catching
there and a lot of pain and started to
fill up with water and I did go to my
doctor and he said well you're currently
just miss you don't have much cartilage
left in there and last week I had to
have it drain and iced teas his credit
he's saying we try to hold off on a knee
replacement as long as you can because
they're not that great for you and if
you can do something that you need and
just nurse along you're better off doing
that but I like it was something to
rebuild the Cartledge if I could how
much you ate okay I weigh 162 I'm 55 I'm
68 years old okay all right this is a
sure thing ok here's Tom charmaine he's
88 years old five foot five hundred 62
pounds and his doctor says he's losing
the cartilage in his knee is swelling
pain what would you do for him to
support all the cartilage and everything
he needs to take to healthy bone and
joint packs ok and how would you divide
data to a healthy bone and joint tax all
those of everything twice a day yeah
except for the glucose oh great how much
will be Joey Mt well he could take
anywhere from 15 to 28 you know capsules
a day absolutely as you say support yeah
support remote means repair and what
else would you give him kind of more
sunshine vitamin what would you give him
I give him vitamin b3 vitamin d3 yeah I
get two bottles of the vitamin d3 go
ahead and take three of those twice a
day and then what you do for stem cells
here this could be a stem cell thing
what would you give them to support stem
cell activity to help him maintain
repair at cartilage I give him something
Mart allium now you got a girl yep mr
challeng to be the way to go there 162
pounds I would go ahead and give you say
maybe three of those twice a day be two
bottles a month and wiki healthy bone
and joint packs are going to get the CM
cream you can apply to the knee itself
or discomfort and if you want to do some
deeper pain charmaine what would you add
to the CM cream I dad to trauma oil to
it absolutely trauma LTR a um a trauma
oil ok from aromatherapy division it's a
blend of oils it will help both relieve
pain so you go ahead and mix five or six
drops to the trauma oil needs teaspoon
of the CM cream you're going to apply
that knee or any other place that you
have pain and use it within 10 minutes
or so you're going to get a significant
or total pain relief or three to five
hours and after a while if we're correct
and you got to stay away for the bad
stuff seek maximize absorption no fried
foods and processed meats no oils no
gluten what foods fall in the gluten
range there Charmaine we barley Ryan
oats yes you got to avoid wheat barley
rye and oats and you know you can still
have rice and buckwheat you have sweet
potatoes that kind of stuff we actually
have a whole division go foods it has a
pre-made meals of prepackaged meals and
also a flower that is gluten-free and so
you can get that called Goku geo foods
and but you got to be gluten-free to
maximize your absorption here and even
people
68 years old we see people who are much
older than that supporting their immune
system is supporting their stem cells
given their body in their genes DNA our
names and telomeres what it needs to
maintain and repair the tissue that's
what these things are designed to do but
they require raw materials enjoy just
like a carpenter needs more than just
the blueprints and the carbon ellison
these tools and nails and supplies such
as wood and that sort of stuff and so
your your body needs the same thing and
so give us a call every couple weeks let
us know how doggie is doing it let us
know how you're done and we'll walk you
guys through this okay thank you very
much for taking my call doctor you bet
okay god bless you Tom and let's see
here how much time we got here got about
20 seconds 20 seconds we'll know Ryan
remind everybody get a hold of the book
doctors don't lie get a hold of the CD
and a DVD debt doctrinal life and find
out why you need to become your own
physician ok don't run to the doctor
first for every little thing otherwise
it increases your cost of your insurance
by putting things on your current record
might want to investigate and do think
yourself as much as you can first ok
well thank you everybody great
testimonies and pleasure drink thank you
so much Charmaine super job as usual
thank you Doug and sam tsui protiv job
as usual god bless each and every one of
you god bless our troops douglas or Navy
SEALs and god bless america
you
[Music]